let's welcome to the Rich Eisen show the
brothers watt JJ TJ and Derek watt whose
new show will be on Fox this Wednesday
night at 9:00 Eastern Time ultimate tag
premiering on the big Fox after the huge
masked singer finale that my kids are
gonna be glued to so they are already
gonna be glued to the watch brothers
good to see you guys how you doing doing
great thank you
you got it all right first questions
first um this is the most burning
question I have we have Jay Jay TJ and
Derek your middle name is if I'm not
mistaken Jon why are you not DJ wat why
is that yeah so this one's been a big
topic I've noticed on Twitter quite
often I just go by Derek I think I was
maybe four or five and I just one day
came home to my mom I just want to be
just Derek okay so they started calling
me just Derek Derek to kind of really
sink it's gonna be different
and the main reasons I feel like you
know I was a kid I didn't really love DJ
Tanner from full house and I got DW from
Arthur so I was like let me just be just
Derek it's kind of started ever since a
young age DJ you seem to have some
commentary on this I mean he explained
that forever it's rude DJ to a full
house he didn't want to be called DJ
caseta is a girl so he went by Derek and
that's the story okay to the subway
commercials of we just find it for 20
years yeah so you had you had some your
visionary coke is that what you're
saying you know yes just trying to help
out the family okay okay and you know
we're on the radio right now as well on
our show on our simulcast so I need to
describe what's going on right now
TJ you look like you're in your kitchen
looks like we see a very nice
refrigerator and some cabinetry behind
you like Derek what do Derek what do we
call what's behind you right now what do
we call that we call it a beautiful
decorative
and some flowers floral arrangement
inside of it
hey it's not mine but it's in the house
my wife kind of likes to decorate and
it's it's here to explain to the radio
viewers if you took the trip sorry I
have a gray wall yes it's the wall is
not fully decorated no I'm not in my
high quality office and of course JJ
you've got the ultimate flex which is
the Walter paid Man of the Year award
that you've got there looks like you
have some very nice photographs what do
we have in the and them in between the
family photographs that you have on
those three things are what are they
teaching they look like some trophies
for Defensive Player of the Year there
and yes we know about it but TJ I mean
you're you're you're circling around
that right you're you're beginning to
zero in on something like that wouldn't
you say I am but you know it close is
just not damn good enough so I'm gonna
have to earn some some of my own
bragging rights and get one of those but
for now JJ can can have that throne he's
got three of them so it's impressive
okay and then those are some photographs
and family photographs or your family
man JJ for me I've got my wife and a
picture of me and my wife some kids
books that I haven't read it again
favorite book oh it's called Total
Access blog this is definitely my
favorite book it's in paperback which I
think where is it everywhere books are
sold JJ everywhere books are sold and
there it is and I happen to have a copy
handy just go go figure that right here
in my house and this is a photograph of
me going out at Michigan Stadium um back
in the day a few years ago and I bring
that up not fully aware what everybody's
record was against Michigan at the
University of Wisconsin I'm not fully
aware of that you've never played in my
career okay that's just
what about unity over one I think it was
just once hopeful on Jacob home
well for me well actually JJ you're
really to a no because again I'm a man
of my word every time I was gonna
interview you on the Rich Eisen show oh
is gonna have this mug that's normally
stationed in studio but I brought it
home just for the occasion
TJ's a girl is it's my tears actually
it's filled with my tears and if you've
seen this mug guys it's that the final
score is yep this past year's debacle um
and it says this cup holds Rich Eisen
steers right there I respect and I
appreciate you saying that and now that
was in case you were all three of you
very upset with the password for this
zoom that I obviously put in there you
wanted to TJ you want to bring that home
for everybody at home what the password
was for the zoom it was Michigan that's
right Justin which again this is this
was a one-time opportunity since I'm
gonna have all three of you together
I've got JJ Watt Derek law TJ want all
sheltered in place how did this all come
about with ultimate tag guys for you to
imagine when you've given an opportunity
that the three of you could all do a TV
show together you jumped at it but I
just want to throw that out there yeah
this opportunity came to me a couple
years ago and they said they had an
opportunity for me to host an executive
producer show called ultimate tag really
the first thought that came to my mind
was it would be perfect opportunity to
my brothers and I to work together and
then we played in the backyard doing up
as kids we have this report where we
kind of rip on each other a little bit
but we also really invested on each
other and I think that was you know
hosting the show so it turned out to be
a lot of fun and we got to spend a ton
of time together while we filmed it
which was really enjoyable TJ yeah like
you said I think the coolest part for us
was that for Derek and I was at JJ even
thought to include us into this show and
when he brought the idea of us hosting a
game show or a competition show Derek
and I at first I know I was
nervous because I've never done anything
to this magnitude and to be able to
commentate and inspect a truly
once-in-a-lifetime experience with the
two of my brothers I'm an ultimate tag
like I said Jada we watched that growing
up we did tag growing up and it's
something that everybody can relate to
and we all had our tough times in being
host me especially I wasn't very good at
reading off the teleprompter and if it
wasn't for these two to get me out of my
own head I don't know if I would have
been able to finish the show what do you
mean I mean have you ever tried reading
off a teleprompter with cameras and
people all around it
yeah what are you talking about I'm
talking to the viewers folks yeah I mean
TJ if they had Defensive Player of the
Year awards for you know reading
teleprompter I have millions of sort of
like your brother
so you didn't you had some you you there
were Slayer encroach besides neutral
zone infractions I mean is that
basically what you had all the above I
think every every rule was broken in the
book and like I said it wasn't for JJ
and Derek I mean JJ made it hard because
he was smashing out of the park like
he's done in every single day of his
life and Derek was all right I mean just
all right but I think I at the end from
where we started where we ended was
night and day Derek yeah he had
struggles there but he struggled with
the teleprompter you know just it was a
lot of fun like you said it was a cool
opportunity for TJ and I we grew like I
said we didn't know we had never done
anything like that in our lives so it
was a very cool opportunity for us
started out rocky and we ended up I
think coming out much better at the end
and we would love an opportunity for
another crack at it season two so which
one which one JJ if you had to award
Most Improved Player to one of your
brothers from the beginning of shooting
to the end who would that's not fair
both older brother who's a lot of fun to
watch them both grow and they really
were legitimately good hopes okay the
end of this show but day 1 of filming
was a rehearsal day and it was you know
I've been talking to the producers this
whole time because I'm an executive you
were I was telling them don't worry my
brother's got this we got this we're
gonna be great it would win it on the
very first day to practice and we get in
front of teleprompter and teach it it
starts to read and for about 20 minutes
we kind of went through these struggles
in the whole time the executive
producers are looking over at me like
man you said we got this li you said
this was gonna be alright
this isn't looking good and to his
credit he came back on day 2 and just
started it much better JJ just kept
saying when the lights come on they'll
be good maybe maybe you TJ you can be
most improved player and Derek you could
be comeback player you know of hosting
we could split these awards and we could
figure that whole thing out and so who
are the people who are running around
like these are just regular normal
everyday people that you would just say
who wants to run around and play tag on
Fox with the the lot brothers kind of
being the judges here so what it is
so the taggers are our professional
taggers are legitimately some of the
best athletes in the world they're
parkour background for the most part one
of them is is the fastest parkour
athlete in the world right now I believe
just some truly phenomenal athletes and
you'll see I mean just by looking at
them you can tell they're they take care
of their bodies they they just train
super hard and they're they do some
incredible things and the competitors
are some every day just everyday people
that wanted to compete and some of them
also have tremendous backgrounds former
athletes themselves growing up somewhere
Olympic athletes and just kind of people
that wanted to give it a shot and we've
got kind of the the wide range of
athletes and it was a cool to hear their
stories and see them compete I mean it
got it got intense for him it was a
grand prize at the end but it was mainly
for pride and they wanted to win and
competing us those Tigers as well as the
other
Brij if you're asking if you can compete
at some point in the future I think we
could possibly well here's a deal JJ
you've seen my straight-line speed okay
um I'm not sure I guess I can work on my
side to side I can kind of work on that
are you more confident or less confident
I think my lateral agility can be worked
on and I think I could look I've been
running from people my entire life so I
just wonder did I hear the words
professional taggers did I hear those
words like is there there's such a thing
where you complete this job in the world
professional tires what is that I guess
you guys are technically you know you
know rough Russian ass or your
professional we have a team of 12 so
like picture American Gladiators back in
the day nitro you have a turbo really
have our team of professional taggers
and they each have their own personality
kind of mantra that they built and so
every week on the show they're the ones
that you have to get by if you want
Enterprise so like Derek said some of
them are parkour some of them are
CrossFit athletes some of them are
former college athletes and they all are
kick a ton of crime and protecting the
ultimate Tiger arena so it's a lot of
fun to watch them and like I said
they're personalities and some of them
are legitimately psychotic
well I'm gonna be locked in my kids are
fired up about the masked singer finale
and again that's Wednesday night and and
you guys are right on me talk about a
great you know time slot for you to come
out of the box the masked singer every
easy number one show on television I
believe at the time so we're looking
forward to you know that I mean by the
way I appreciate using capitalizing that
that's a big pressure you got to hold
time slots that's basically this is what
you you know this is what you guys have
to do I mean our first option was so
option two they said you exactly what to
say to the host and you're you're the
savvy veteran of this brothers group
that's for damn sure
do I get like one legitimate football
question to ask each of you can I can I
do that sort of thing all right first
things first
JJ the trading away of DeAndre
Hopkins did that shock you did you see
it coming yeah definitely catches your
eye shocks in a little bit but you know
the one thing people people ask me know
what what are your feelings on this how
do you feel and I think a lot of people
want me to be angry about it or whatever
it is and the thing that I always tell
people is this to me is as the best
hands in the game he's one of the best
receivers in the game here do I am I
gonna miss watching hop make circus
catches for us and make huge plays
absolute but you also have to remember
that there are two players coming to my
team in this trade and to disrespect
them by saying you know I wish we
wouldn't have done this I have to just
like remember game these guys are my
teammates not looking forward as a
player it's a very fine line used to
walking and train situations and talking
about things like that pop is without a
doubt one of the best players in the
game that's always tough to lose a guy
like that but at the same time we also
have guys coming that I'm looking
forward to working with at the end of
the day it's up to the GM the coach and
the owners to make those types of the
cities and then they have to live with
those costs and in terms of working
Derek you know again everybody looks at
players and coaches and everybody in
sports is if they're you know got the
Cure to cope at 19 have you been
any indication of when you might
physically be able to get into a spot
anywhere for you so no real indication
is honestly right now we're doing our
virtual meetings every Monday we have a
team meeting zoom and then we break off
in our meetings and coach Tomlin touches
base on that just kind of keeping us
updated to the latest that he knows but
honestly I don't think until pretty much
the whole country kind of gets on on
board where every all 32 teams can go
into their facilities or at least find a
facility to then go work out at its
trying to keep the competitive advantage
where everybody is on the same playing
field so I really it's kind of up in the
air until things get under control and
right now it's just kind of TJ said
earlier just kind of getting ready
staying ready so you don't have to get
ready so you don't have to get ready
just kind of stay on top of your things
whatever they say let's go we're ready
to go we just hear your prompter reading
skills in real time did that just happen
oh I wasn't reading anything I'm just I
know you're there as I saw the reaction
your brother's right there start
laughing at you not getting the line
right properly but you know recovery I
could see that again Comeback Player of
the Year
Gehrig won and TJ you know look it was a
wild subject that came out of the blue
with James Harrison last week your coach
allegedly giving him an envelope ten
years ago after he got fined for a hit
on a player in James Harrison have you
seen Tomlin do anything like that in
your time there I have and I wasn't even
anything associated with the
organization ten years ago but now coach
Tomlin is a stand-up guy it's always
been very well to me and the whole team
and the one thing I love about him is
his transparency he treats everybody
fairly and he's just a great players
coach but I do not I do not see him
doing anything like that and I have not
and I don't think I don't know from
firsthand but I don't need that happen
no I know that seems to be totally out
of character for for for Mike Tomlin yes
yeah I mean he has total control of the
whole team and is it as a great leader
and not always knows what to saying what
to do in every situation but I do not
see anything like this happening with
him alright that means the legitimate
NFL questions portion of this interview
before I let you guys go off to again
the big premiere Wednesday night on Fox
9:00 eastern time after the masked
singer finale ultimate tag earlier on
Wednesday
JJ NBC announced that NBC SN is going to
start re-airing Saturday Night Live
hosting gigs by athletes this is true by
the way yours is going to air next
Tuesday on NBC SN Brady and paint
Manning's are going to be that night as
well Derek and TJ how would you rate
your brothers Saturday night lon
hosting gig what do you think was his
best sketch that we're gonna see next
Tuesday night right here on NBCSN TJ
what do you think I mean it was kind of
awkward to watch premiere because we
were with my grandma and there was a lot
of a lot of things that need to be
censored in that whole program but I
thought I mean the Olaf was funny the
parents talking to their kid was funny I
had the pizza delivery guy I mean I'm
just trying to think of more I can't I
think overall it was a really cool
opportunity for JJ to show everybody his
funny side and we get to see it on a
daily basis but for him to be able to do
something different and to smash out of
the park I mean like he said I had a
tough time with been doing TV but he got
to do it live on a huge stage and I
think he did a absolutely amazing job
and it was cool to see a small kid from
Pewaukee that you grew up with on the
biggest stage in TV they're tearing up
JJ they're just I feel like this is like
a group hug Derek were you there too
when for the group was there yes what
happened with Grandma what happened no
so we were watching with a big group my
parents my grandma and I don't think
grandma knew what she was getting into I
don't think it was quite the show she
was expecting so yeah some of the
innuendos the yeah just some of the
skits can we're a little bit raunchy you
might say yes but yes she was she was
not holding back she was like pop JJ I
am shocked she was not she was
disappointed at a few of the skits I
think I think I said dude you might have
lost a few brownie points with Grandma
boy but it was worth every penny right
it was worth every single moment for you
I'm a child it was a blast I mean
there's a great time sir than I'll
absolutely one of the most iconic shows
on television so just to have that
opportunity to work with
Michael's to be on the set to be out
there with the people I mean it was
really something that I've had big
dreams before in my life and that's not
something that never even came into my
realm of possible so the chance to do
that was special and I really enjoyed
every single second of its the
production is unbelievable with those
people who ever read across a
traditional well just make sure that
grandma what's grandma's name I'm sorry
I want to keep referring her was okay
make sure that between 10:00 and 11:00
p.m. Eastern on next Tuesday night that
she is not watching and a bouquet of
flowers here in the next couple days I
realize it was as bad as these two
amazing sorry for breaking it to you
[Music]
okay well look thanks for coming on
really appreciate it guys thanks for
typing in the word Michigan to get into
this zoom room it means a lot to me and
good luck with ultimate tag premiering
again on Fox 9:00 eastern time with you
guys TJ and JJ and Derek I hope it sees
successful is possible that we can get
stuff on your wall and potentially a
little bit more of an arrangement back
there and then the Willows or whatever
if you got going on there with all due
respect to whoever is in charge of your
house I'm only watching the success
really think you mean awesome Derek abut
out and I appreciate you guys are
first-rate first class thanks for doing
this guy's really pretty oh my gosh
that's JJ Watt TJ watt and Derek watt
right here on the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here